mit dem euro werden kriegsverbrechen
finanziert das ist den meisten in den
letzten wochen bewusst geworden auch
deshalb weil es unsere eigene existenz
unsere zukunft gefährden kann putin den
geldhahn zum beispiel für öl und gas
zuzudrehen heißt aber auch und schon
jetzt in schwierigkeiten zu bringen für
eine gute sache aber wo liegt die grenze
wo boykott mehr schadet als nützt eine
knifflige frage
gas und öl aus russland können wir uns
das noch leisten jetzt in der phoenix
runde
phoenix runde
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen bei uns meine gäste
zunächst im studio ist cordula tutt sie
sind korrespondentin der
wirtschaftswoche hier in berlin michael
kruse ist bei uns energiepolitischer
sprecher der fdp-bundestagsfraktion
zugeschaltet sind und es hermann josef
tenhagen chefredakteur von finanztest
und ludwig möhring sie sind
hauptgeschäftsführer des bundesverbandes
erdgas erdöl und georgi kruse die
spritpreise die erreichen der
astronomische höhen der rabatt vorschlag
ihres parteivorsitzenden christian
lindner bis zu 40 bis zu 40 cent pro
liter
gleich an der tankstellen kasse zurück
zu erstatten
ist das die richtige reaktion jetzt in
diesem moment ja ich meine schon denn
viele menschen in diesem land suchen
sich ja nicht aus ob die große strecken
fahren ich nehme als beispiel die
pendlerinnen und pendler die natürlich
über große distanzen fahren müssen und
das ziel aller maßnahmen die wir jetzt
ergreifen muss ja sein wladimir putin zu
treffen das regime um ihn herum zu
treffen und nicht größere schäden in
deutschland zu produzieren als in
russland flott bei dem thema tank rabatt
aller christian lindner gibt es auch
widerspruch und andere meinungen was
spricht dagegen also ich bin etwas
überrascht von diesem vorschlag weil es
ja gerade von einer partei kommt die
normalerweise den markt und preissignale
wichtig findet und dieses mittel hat
jetzt die völlig falschen anreize es
teuer für den staat hat wenig effekt für
die bürgerinnen und bürger und bringt im
zweifelsfall nur den gewinnen die
ohnehin gerade schon reichlich gewinne
machen raffinerien und andere unterlagen
sie sind ja sozusagen
gewissermaßen der schutzheilige der
verbraucher wie können den
autofahrerinnen und autofahrer sinnvoll
entlastet werden
also sinnvoll entlastet werden können
sie können sie sich selber wenn sie eine
tank app benutzen die tanks werden im
augenblick so viel genutzt dass sie viel
langsamer geworden sind sagen auch die
betreiber selber da kann man 15 20 cent
pro liter sparen das zweite was man
machen könnte man gründet hat mal in
raffinerien auf den fuss stehen es kann
ja nicht sein dass das rohöl 10 15 20
cent pro liter teurer wird und der sprit
diese 55 cent an der tanksäule da ist
möglicherweise auch noch was anderes
passiert und es gibt ja auch leute aus
den aus der landwirtschaft die durch
aussagen die raffinerien verdienen im
augenblick gut also mit einer wurden
kriegsgewinnler das brauchen wir
eigentlich nicht und da könnte sich auch
eine regierung darum kümmern dass sowas
nicht passiert und das dritte ist was
man macht man natürlich immer machen
kann man kann spritsparen der adac und
immer vor wie man mit einem auto was
normalerweise acht liter sprit braucht
für die gleiche strecke auch mit sechs
liter sprit fahren kann man beim
bayerischen rundfunk schöne videos
angucken empfehle ich immer allen leuten
die mich fragen wie man den sprit sparen
kann gehörigen dieser hinweis von herrn
ten hagen auf diesen preisdifferenz
zwischen benzin und rohöl woher kommt
das eigentlich sie sind ja da involviert
sie vertreten ja die
erdöl erdgas geoenergie wirtschaft gibt
es dafür eine erklärung dass zwar auch
der rohölpreis erheblich angestiegen ist
aber nicht so stark wie benzin und
diesel
also ich spreche regelmäßig nicht für
den raffinerie betrieb hier in
deutschland das ist ein anderer verband
aber lassen sie mich eines sagen also
ich bin mir sehr sicher dass aktuell
alle jene wertschöpfungskette aktiv sind
sehr genau schauen auf das was sie
machen und ich kann mir kaum vorstellen
dass in den ferien gerade ihr die
angesprochene kriegsgewinnler hier sich
selber ins schaufenster stellen
sozusagen
ja die da gerne noch nachlegen wenn ich
darauf sicher also wenn sie wenn sie
heizöl kaufen in berlin kaufte kostet
das im augenblick ein euro 80 wenn sie
heute am niederrhein kaufen kostet er im
augenblick ein euro 30 erklärte mir das
bitte mal als die raffinerie damals in
ingolstadt explodiert ist was ein
richtig großes problem für die
mineralölwirtschaft aber der
preisunterschied zehn cent bundesweiten
jetzt haben wir da 50 bis er noch
erklären herr möhringen vertreter wenn
ich die mineralölwirtschaft hat gerade
jetzt auch darauf hingewiesen und die
wirtschaft wenn man so will also sagt er
vor produkt aber trotzdem war es ja an
sie gerichtet haben
auch hier sehen wir meiner ansicht nach
an einen effekt der sich gerade
tatsächlich außer existierenden logistik
für rohöl und ölprodukte in deutschland
zeigt nämlich dass ein großteil des des
öls das im osten der bundesrepublik hier
verwandt genutzt und auch raffiniert
wird aus russland kommt und das sind
würde ich erwarten hier die konsequenzen
mit den velaro umzugehen haben jetzt
gibt es eine generelle frage frau tot
diese hohen
energiepreise insgesamt also den die
gesamte das gesamte energie angebot
meine ich jetzt ist es eher eine mangel
an angebot geschuldet oder vor allen
dingen der spekulation also im moment
kann man so drastischen mangel noch
nicht sehen ist es eher die erwartung
des mangels und eine spekulation die
darauf aufbaut diese enormen
preisunterschiede die ja gerade schon
angesprochen wurden beim öl jetzt
speziell die kommen natürlich daher dass
es im moment ein zweigeteiltes
deutschland immer noch gibt also
ostdeutschland wird per pipeline mit öl
aus russland vor allem versorgt und hat
wenig andere zugänge und im westen des
landes gibt es billigere
konkurrenzfähige hre versorgung also das
ist sicher ein punkt und im moment haben
wir noch keinen mangel nicht an gas
nicht an kohle nicht an öl wohl das
russische öl und die russische kohle
werde neben vermieden
insofern wird es teurer klar aber wir
haben im moment eher die erwartungen
dass es anders wird das vielleicht sogar
ein embargo oder ein lieferstopp haben
darauf kommen wir auch noch der die
hohen spritpreise sind ja eine
mittelbare folge dass ukraine kriegst du
vielleicht noch mal auf das was ihr
parteivorsitzender da vorgeschlagen hat
am seine überlegung oder eine
vorstellung was das kosten würde 40 cent
pro liter
sollen wir drei monate vielleicht ein
realistischer zeitrahmen in dem diese
dieser ukraine krieg weitergeht und
damit auch auswirkungen auf die
energiepreise hat was das kosten kann
ist ja von hohen milliardenbeträgen die
jetzt aber ehrlich gesagt gar nicht
meine erwartungshaltung denn wir haben
ja in den letzten zwei tagen schon eine
deutliche entspannung an den weltmärkten
für brandt gesehen also für öl das heißt
mit der fortlaufenden
auseinandersetzung geht ein bisschen
hysterie aus dem markt raus damit fallen
die preise im ölbereich schon wieder das
heißt das wird nicht die dauerhafte
situation sollen wir haben natürlich
darüber noch einen weiteren effekt
gehabt nämlich dass der euro stark
abgewertet hat gegenüber dem dollar das
alles wird alles im ölbereich wird in
dollar gehandelt das bedeutet wir haben
einen zusätzlichen währungseffekt
gesehen das wird aber beides nicht
dauerhaft sein ich möchte noch mal ganz
kurz auf die raffinerien zu sprechen
kommen weil ich glaube da ist eine
entscheidende dreh und angelpunkt wir
haben gerade aktuell die diskussion in
schwedt wo eine hundertprozentige
russische tochter gerne sich noch
erweitern möchte noch den anteil erhöhen
möchte da möchte ich mal das
fragezeichen dahinter machen das thema
war sind die raffinerien diejenigen die
im moment gute ergebnisse erzielen ich
stelle mir die frage wen sollten die
raffinerien in deutschland denn
eigentlich gehören und wollen wir
eigentlich dass russland jetzt auch noch
an den deutschen raffinerien ordentlich
mit profitiert ich meine das
bundesministerium sollte diese
erweiteren untersagen ist dass durch die
sanktionsmassnahmen nicht ausgeschlossen
im moment nein das ist nicht
ausgeschlossen die sind ja schon
beteiligt und deswegen meine ich es
liegt gerade zur prüfung beim
bundeswirtschaftsministerium und
deswegen wäre es wichtig dass der
bundeswirtschaftsminister hier eine
klare entscheidung trifft gegen diese
erweiterung des anteils glaube ich habe
nicht nach ergänzen das bundeskartellamt
hatte am 21
drei tage vor kriegsbeginn diese abend
dieser aufstockung des anteils von
rosneft in spät genehmigt nämlich von 53
prozent auf anfang 90 prozent ihren die
anteile von shell dann gekauft drei tage
vor den krieger sind offenbar mindestens
insgesamt in der regierung niemand so
recht darauf gesehen aber die hat ja
auch anteile an den raffinerien in baden
württemberg und bayern in den letzten
jahren gekauft und direkt nach dem
einmarsch der russen auf der krim da
waren die regierung auch nicht so auf
der höhe der zeit kann man so sagen hat
gazprom den größten gasspeicher der
republik in rehden gekauft es ist sogar
zu sogar zunächst mal zurückgestellt
worden wegen dieses einmarsches aber
nachher fand man energie sicherheit sei
nicht gefährdet und hat dann das doch
genügt ich finde im moment werden aber
zwei verschiedene ebenen vermengt das
eine ist das ja kurzfristigen was herr
linden die welt gesetzt hat was die
verbraucher entlasten sondern das andere
ist ja strategisch wie wir uns weiter
aufstellen und so unabhängiger bis
unabhängig von russland machen bei
debatten müssen wir führen ja aber
und zwar der reihe nach ich habe nur
noch eine frage an herrn mögen dem
zusammenhang auf was müssen wir uns den
beiden den energiepreisen einstellen
also bei erdöl bei erdgas in der
nächsten zeit ist da die preisspitze
schon erreicht oder gibt es auch
hinweise wir sehen uns noch nicht ob es
ein embargo gibt gegen russisches öl und
gas gibt es da hinweise dass das nicht
das ende der fahnenstange war
wir müssen aktuell herr keller in
letzten diesen szenarien hier denken die
die einen nennen aktuelle preise von
spekulation getrieben ich bin eher
waltraud wie gesagt hier wir gehen auch
erwartungen mit in die preise rein und
machen wir uns nichts vor so lange
lieferunterbrechungen wer auch immer sie
nach jeder heraus spricht von von
lieferungen aus russland
solange die im raum sind werden wir
davon ausgehen müssen dass das preise
regionen erreichen die wir die wir lange
nicht gesehen haben beim gas übrigens
noch nie gesehen haben nicht wir haben
in der vergangenen woche gebe ihnen mal
ein beispiel eine preis höhe an den
märkten gesehen die war jenseits von dem
was dimitri medwedew in aussicht
gestellt hatte als preise auf die sich
europa einstellen müssen und ich würde
mal vermuten dass er da er oben ins
regal gegriffen hat und was uns hier
sehr deutlich macht wie schnell märkte
reagieren können wenn bestimmte
erwartungshaltungen wandel da vorhanden
sind in der lage sie haben anfang der
sendung auf die nachfragemacht der
verbraucher abgehoben können wir das ist
vielleicht noch etwas detaillierter
sagen beim thema energiesparen
energieeffizienz was ist da noch möglich
es gibt ja noch andere ideen was man da
machen könnte um energie zu sparen
tempolimit ist auch ein thema das immer
wieder auftaucht in dem zusammenhang
könnten sie das was der verbraucher
angesichts dieser hohen preise die auf
dem gesamten energiesektor ihn jetzt
betreffen bei der mobilität beim wohnen
oder auch die unternehmen was da noch
möglich ist um diese kosten in grenzen
zu halten welchen einfluss verbraucher
und unternehmen da nehmen können
na ja wir haben es schon als verbraucher
einfluss weil wir bestimmte
stellschrauben können wir selber schauen
das eine ist das thermostat zu hause in
der heizung also erst mal ein
ordentliches neuen ist thermostat dazu
haben was sich mit der porto regelungen
erlaubt und dann vielleicht auch zwei
grad weiter unter druck bringt natürlich
eine menge den klempner zu beauftragen
wenn man die heizung selber im griff hat
dass er mal die heizung wieder
ausbalancieren bringt auch eine menge da
kann man auch was dran machen man kann
natürlich an allen möglichen enden in
der wohnung energiesparen das gleiche
gilt beim auch da hab ich eben
spritsparender autofahren geht schon 20
25 prozent weniger geht da per se tempo
130 bringt gegenüber 160 ein drittel
einsparungen die herrschaften bei
greenpeace am ausgerechnet beim tempo
100 würden wir so ungefähr so viel
sparen wie man da an dem in dem bereich
an sprit sparen könnte das will ja
vielleicht auch mal für einige wochen
oder monaten eine möglichkeit das zu tun
solche dinge gehen die die kann man
selber anfassen das problem ist da hat
der herr von der fdp ja eben schon recht
aber wir haben einen haufen pendler in
deutschland den haben wir gesagt ihr
könnt von a nach b zur arbeit fahren das
ist vernünftig und realistisch und die
für die ist das zum teil jetzt nicht
mehr vernünftig und realistisch von
denen müssen wir helfen gleichzeitig
dann können wir bei den anderen auch
sagen leute ihr müsst euch einstellen
ihr müsst das anders machen ist
vielleicht das nächste auto ein anderes
kaufen vielleicht auch im auto aber
denjenigen die sich selbst im augenblick
nicht helfen können denen muss man
helfen und
ich muss sie leider mit unterbrechen
weil er genau das passiert ist was
wir versucht haben für die sendung zu
vermeiden dass jetzt aber kommt nämlich
etwas aktuelles aus der ukraine 3
ministerpräsidenten auf osteuropa sind
dorthin gefahren um den präsidenten zu
lentzke zu sprechen jetzt gibt es dazu
eine pressekonferenz
wir sind hier um zu zeigen wie wir ihren
kampf bewundern gegen diesen grausamen
aggressor die invasionen muss
das blut auf den straßen ihre mütter
kinder und ehefrauen sind in sicherheit
aber diejenigen die von putin getötet
werden werden nie in vergessenheit
geraten und die europäische union muss
schnell ein kandidatenstatus für sie
einrichten und darüber hinaus die
ukraine in die eu einladen
sämtliche
verteidigungswaffen für das land sind
erforderlich wir werden
eine zusammenarbeit in der ganzen welt
orchestrieren wir werden sie niemals
alleine lassen wir werden an ihrer seite
stehen denn sie kämpfen nicht nur für
sie für ihre sicherheit und ihr zuhause
sondern auch für uns wir sind hier um
ihrem mut unsere bewunderung
auszudrücken den kampf gegen die
russische armee zu unterstützen denn sie
kämpfen auch unser gefecht sie
verteidigen nicht nur unsere ihre heimat
sondern auch die heimat europa sie
verteidigen auch etwas das wir die
fundamentalen europäischen werte nennen
freiheit demokratie und
das recht eines jeden
seiner seine freiheit super seine
freiheit zu bestimmen über sein leben zu
bestimmen und wir tun alles in unserer
macht stehende um ihnen zu helfen den
geflüchteten zu helfen die aus der
ukraine kommen und wir wissen genau dass
das wichtigste jetzt daran besteht der
ukraine mit waffen hilfe zu leisten
damit
die sich verteidigen kann sich auf dem
land auf dem wasser und auf dem luftweg
zu verteidigen und wir möchten auch die
einheit der europäischen union hier da
stellen nämlich die familie der 27
mitglieder da stellen wir unterstützen
ihren kampf ihre souveränität und das
ist etwas das wir ganz kurz erreicht
haben wenn man das mal vergleicht mit
anderen lagen in der kürzlichen
geschichte
wir möchten ihnen hier auch sagen
dass sie weiterhin mutig sein sollten
okra die ukraine ist in europa
eingebettet und
das was in unserer macht steht wollen
wir tun und wir möchten
die mitgliedschaft in der eu sie als weg
bereiten und das so schnell wie möglich
und zwar nicht nur als konkreten schritt
zur unterstützung bat auch als maßnahme
für diejenigen die in die ukraine
einmarschiert sind sie sind teil unserer
familie
unsere familien sind bereit die ukraine
zu verteidigen und sie zu unterstützen
und ich denke im moment
steht das außer frage
dass das land das die europäischen werte
am meisten
verteidigt die ukraine ist und plötzlich
ist es innerhalb der europäischen union
so wo wir ja über die
grundwerte sprechen
erkennen müssen dass diese werte auch
wirklich bestehen
[Musik]
das land europäer die für diese werte
kämpfen die sie verteidigen mit ihren
eigenen leben innerhalb der ukraine
und das ist der grund aus
dem die atmosphäre und die stimmung
innerhalb der
neuen mitgliedsländer sich signifikant
verändert das ist nämlich jetzt der
moment in dem hunderttausende
menschen auf die straßen gehen in europa
um ihre unterstützung auszudrücken sie
sind nicht alleine sie sind teil unserer
familie behalten sie ihren mut sie
werden bin gemeinsam werden wir gewinnen
es ist eine große freude hier zu sein
und es ist eine große gelegenheit die so
wichtig ist heute abend hier in kiew mit
ihnen persönlich zusammen zu stehen und
sie möchten damit unsere unterstützung
für ihren kampf demonstrieren
unsere unterstützung für irland
wir bewundern ihre mutigen kampf und sie
kämpfen für ihre leben für ihre familien
ihr land für die freiheit aber
sie kämpfen auch für unsere leben und
unsere freiheit das wissen wir zu
schätzen und möglicherweise ist das
wesentliche ziel unseres besuches häuser
oder sagen wir mal die wesentliche
botschaft
sagen dass sie nicht allein sind
unsere länder stehen an ihrer seite
europa steht an ihrer seite
des terrorismus des präsidenten um der
staatsführung für das terrorismus der
ganzen nation und auch das mitgefühl für
alle die opfer geworden sind aber dieses
mitgefühl kann keine leere worthülse
sein es muss etwas weitergeben ich
möchte hier in kiew ihnen sagen
einige worte
sich an die
führer der europäischen union und nato
wenden ich möchte an ihrer gewissen
appellieren aber auch an ihrer
konsequenzen also sie
predigen gewisse prinzipien und vitalen
diese prinzipien aber wenn man solche
prinzipien predigt dann muss man auch
daraus konsequenzen ziehen man macht man
braucht die hilfe von der wir gesprochen
haben von der präsident gestorben hat
ich denke dass man
gewisse prinzip ändern muss jemand
angenommen hat ich denke dass man eine
friedensmission braucht eine nato
friedensmission und vielleicht eines
seiner anderen
und dann hat sie nur noch auf nationaler
eine mission die imstande wäre
sich zu
auf dem der regierung von reinert eine
mission die hier auf diesem territorium
wirken könnte natürlich mit
einverständnis der ukrainischen behörden
eine mission die nicht wehrlos wäre eine
mission die zum frieden macht den
frieden streben würde aber die auch
durch gewisse der
militärische mittel geschützt wäre
keine europa und die ganze demokratische
welt braucht das ich denke das ist der
richtige ort dafür
dieser ort
und dieser ort
von dem aus
dem man
also ich möchte das an alle präsidenten
entscheidungsträger sagen in europa den
vereinigten staaten und in der ganzen
welt es geht nicht nur um anerkennung
worte und solidarität sondern es geht um
die taten es geht darum was wirklich
benötigt wird um die den mut in den mut
den mann so oft fehlt
ja soweit die pressekonferenz der
ministerpräsidenten von tschechien polen
und slowenen heute abend in der ukraine
der polnische regierungschef hat sich
gleich noch sekundieren lasst uns
sozusagen stellvertreter stanislawski
jeans geht er zum schluss gesprochen hat
die reise ist ja wegen ihrer
gefährlichkeit auch in der europäischen
union nicht unumstritten mehr zu diesem
thema nachher in der sendung phoenix der
tag wir sind jetzt zurück in der phoenix
runde mit dem titel gas und öl aus
russland was können wir uns noch leisten
herr kruse
hermann josef tenhagen hat ja gerade
über die einsparmöglichkeiten gesprochen
aber über die
nachfragemacht die verbraucher haben
diese hohen sprit- und energiepreise
etwas zu dämpfen weil das wird natürlich
nicht ausreichend welche staatlichen
unterstützungsmaßnahmen brauchen wir
dennoch es gibt ja das energie geld das
ist aber steht im koalitionsvertrag ist
aber noch nicht ausgearbeitet
konzeptioniert es gibt den
heizkostenzuschuss wegen der hohen
gaspreise vor allen dingen sind
vielleicht auch noch steuersenkungen
nötig eine erhöhung der pendlerpauschale
was ist davon der koalition die sie hier
jetzt repräsentieren von der
ampelkoalition zu erwarten ja zunächst
mal gibt es ja neben den beiden
maßnahmen die sich schon aufgezählt
haben auch noch die abschaffung der
eeg-umlage die wir jetzt vorgezogen
haben der erste schritt ist ja schon
passiert zum 1 1 22 der zweite war für
anfang 23 geplant wird jetzt aufgrund
der steigenden preise auf mitte dieses
jahres vorgezogen das ist ein
entlastungspaket im zweistelligen
milliarden-bereich das erst noch wirksam
wird und darüber hinaus müssen wir aber
natürlich genau schauen wo entstehen
diese entwicklung dauerhaft im ölbereich
haben wir eben besprochen ist
substituieren russischen öls möglich wir
haben einen weltmarkt wir können
anderswo kaufen es dauert ein bisschen
aber es möglich im gasbereich ist es
nicht ganz so leicht zum einen hat
russland einen wesentlich höheren anteil
an unserem gase- und zum zweiten ist
wenn wir substituieren über lg dauert es
etwas länger das aufzubauen und es ist
auch etwas teurer das heißt im
gasbereich müssen wir ansetzen zb indem
wir an die energiesteuern rangehen das
wäre mein vorschlag dass wir energie
steuern bei strom und bei gas senken
weil wir dadurch auch sehr schnellen
entlastungseffekt erzielen können
es gibt ja viele unternehmen die jetzt
leiden unter denen auch unter den hohen
energiepreisen selbst in der
energiewirtschaft gibt es ja probleme
was hilft denn da am meisten er kredite
oder auch überbrückungshilfen
auch steuersenkung was erwartet die
wirtschaft jetzt auch speziell die
energiewirtschaft wie der staat auf
diese hohen energiepreise reagiert und
wir auch den wirtschaftszweigen da unter
die arme greift
das sind sehr wichtiger punkt der kehler
zu recht haben wir haben wir hier gerade
sehr ausführlich gesprochen über über
die verbraucher und die konsequenzen und
die möglichkeiten die wir im bereich der
verbraucher haben wenn wir zehn erdgas
auch in deutschland anschauen dann ist
eben ganz ganz wichtig dass dass über
ein drittel des erdgasverbrauchs von den
von den industrieunternehmen verbraucht
wird industrieunternehmen die in vielen
keine chance haben vernünftig zu
reagieren insbesondere dann wenn sie
international im wettbewerb stehen
irgendwas ist eine eine für viele
unternehmen wenn etwas länger anhalten
würde eine dramatische situation wir
können sicherlich gleich noch zu der
frage was passiert eigentlich wenn ein
stopp käme noch haben wir uns richtig
gesagt offenbar keine versorgungskrise
sondern um eine preiskrise im meine
sorge hier ist muss ich ihnen ganz
ehrlich sagen dass aus sicht der
bundesregierung hier vergleichsweise
wenig zu tun ist eine reihe von den
entlastungen von denen hier gerade bei
den verbrauchern die rede ist sind ja
bislang bei den großindustrie gar nicht
vorhanden ist die zahlen keine keine die
eeg umlage zum beispiel richtig große
unternehmen unter präzise zu sein ich
sehe das schwere zeiten auf die
unternehmen zukommen ich sehe aber auch
schwere zeiten zukommen auf eine reihe
von energieunternehmen im moment die an
der börse mit mit von hohen strom- und
von hohen gaspreisen oder mit denen von
diesen preisen konfrontiert sind und die
an ein hohes maß an liquidität auf
einmal zur verfügung stellen müssen eine
liquidität die sie dann vielfach nicht
haben und wo wie sie gerade jetzt über
darlehen von der kfw ausgleichen müssen
das ist natürlich eine ausgesprochen
hilfreich aktion hier was ihnen nicht
unsere großen energieunternehmen auch
noch in schwierigkeiten da für ein
stichwort gewesen und wirken würde ich
gern an die frage an herrn tenhaken
weiterreichen viele verbraucher haben ja
erlebt dass ihre energie ihr
gasversorgungsunternehmen sie plötzlich
rausgeschmissen hat aus dem vertrag weil
dieses unternehmen diese hohen preise
gar nicht mehr refinanzieren konnte wenn
man sich mal generell diesen gasmarkt
ansieht worden waren da auch wild west
methoden unterwegs weil das bedeutet ja
wer aus dem vertrag raus fliegt weil er
kein gas mehr von seinem bisherigen
vertragspartner bekommt geht dann die
sogenannte grundversorgung über das sind
meistens die unternehmen mit den
höchsten
gaspreisen was ist auf diesem gasmarkt
eigentlich passiert jetzt und was jetzt
sozusagen das resultat ist dieser hohen
gaspreise das war ja schon vor dem
ukraine krieg so ist das zu wenig
reguliert worden was war der grund für
diese misere
da ist in jedem fall auch ein stückweit
regulierungen die fehlt also wer will
der westen hat er tatsächlich existiert
man da gibt es geltender verträge und
dann sagt er einen vertragspartner
einfach ich habe keine lust mehr ich
kann ihn ja und hat sich offenbar auch
nicht präpariert und da reden wir nicht
von der zeit vor dem zeitpunkt gibt es
krieg sondern wir reden von dem
zeitpunkt im letzten herbst sie haben
sich nicht präpariert dafür dass sie
ihre lieferungen wird nicht
gewährleisten können das heißt sie sind
am markt und können eigentlich ihren
dienst gar nicht anbieten weil sie nicht
machen können zum teil gibt es auch noch
verdacht dass da durchaus geld verdient
wird ist und dann einfach nicht mehr
wollte um die alten gewinnen nicht zu
gefährden das kann natürlich weil sowas
die energieversorgung eigentlich so
nicht sein da muss regulierungen so gut
sein dass die das auf jeden fall dass
die anbieter auf jeden fall das liefern
können teil 1 teil 2 ist ja gut das ist
die grundversorgung in deutschland gibt
das heißt nirgendwo ist die bude kalt
geworden nirgendwo ist der strom
ausgefallen
obwohl es diese probleme mit einzelnen
anbietern gab also davon hat die
regulierung wie gut funktioniert was
dann nicht funktioniert hat dass das ein
oder andere der ein oder andere
grundversorgern und versorger dann der
meinung war er könnte seinen strompreis
von 33 cent auf 1 euro auf schrauben
weil die leute ja nirgendwo anders hin
können dann kann man ja von den von den
von diesen kunden kann man es annehmen
das ist im ruhrgebiet losgegangen und
war im südwesten gold gab's dann vor
zahlen war glaube ich der spitzenreiter
mit 1 euro 4 für pro kilowattstunde
strom das eigentlich unvorstellbar und
das muss dann erst wieder von anderen
stromanbietern über gerichtsverfahren
eingefangen werden auch da würde man
sich erwarten dass regulierung
eigentlich so funktioniert dass so was
in der form nicht stattfinden
die kunden die können sich da nämlich
nicht gut wären also wir sehen sie
könnten dann wird sozusagen hinterher
versucht ob sie irgendwie geld bei dem
anbieter darunter stimmt zwar
zurückholen im augenblick können sie
aber nirgendwo anders hin können auch
diese verträge nicht kündigen sie sind
da bisschen gefangen und müssen
hinterher das wieder zusammen fäden und
das ist eigentlich auch nicht sinnvoll
weil der einzelne kunde der redet dann
über 300 euro unter den
durchschnittsdeutschen der cluster klagt
nicht wegen 300 euro seien ihm oder
gasversorger das machen die einfach
nicht ich bin ich auch nicht machen
natürlich bin ich ihr herz wenn ich kurz
ergänzen gab also ganz ehrlich ich finde
einen ganzjährigen beim benzin hagen ich
erwarte ehrlich gesagt eine reihe von
von rechtlichen verfahren denn so
einfach rausschmeißen geht ja mal nicht
ganz kurzer zur kommerziellen
beschreibung dessen was da passiert ist
ich formal immer so gut gemanagte
stadtwerke in deutschland haben ein
risikomanagement die fundament das
fundamental dazu führen wenn die eine
vielzahl von kunden an der vielzahl von
kunden strom für das kommende jahr zu
einem bestimmten preis verkauft dass
dieser strom auch in dem moment
eingekauft wird man ist sozusagen
gehedgt ja dann ist der strompreis klar
auf der einkaufs- und auf der
verkaufsseite diesen unternehmen
passiert in dem moment nämlich dann
nichts mehr wenn die preise im laufe der
zeit hochgehen sollte nun gucken wir auf
eine reihe von jahren zurück wo
diejenigen die nicht den strom den sie
verkauft hatten eingekauft hatten
sondern und da bin ich dann seine hellen
haaren und sage das ist spekulation die
haben spekuliert darauf dass wenn dir
der lieferzeitpunkt näher kommt dass die
preise sinken und die wollten dann mehr
geld verdienen und die sind in der
situation als die marktpreise auf einmal
nach oben gegangen sind schlicht auf der
falschen seite des marktes gewesen und
haben verluste gemacht die sind keiner
weise mehr ertragen kann das eine form
von risikomanagement die meiner ansicht
nach nichts mit einer soliden
unternehmensführung nichts zu tun und
wir haben auch gesehen welche
unternehmen nicht darunter gelitten habe
und welche unternehmen ist durchgehalten
gut das war jetzt noch zur klarstellung
zur ergänzung noch mal es war ja nicht
ursächlich der ukraine kriegt dafür
verantwortlich das gab es ja auch schon
vorher mit steigenden aber für ein ende
exakt beginnende steigende gaspreise die
dazu geführt haben letzten endes bei ja
nun gas in die stromerzeugung geht dass
die stromerzeugung im preis höhen
gegangen ist die man wie man nicht und
hier brauchen wir dafür rächen wollen
ehrlich gesagt also ich würde da
widersprechen wollen der wärme in diesem
winter und zum beginn des winters zwei
effekte gesehen die von russland
ausgegangen sind der erste ist russland
hat systematisch die gasspeicher in
deutschland 30 prozent der gasspeicher
in deutschland sind unter russischen
einfluss die haben die systematisch er
hat das zweite ist sie haben sich an den
spotmärkten sehr zurückgehalten das
heißt sie haben nur die langfristigen
verträge bedient die folge all derer die
gesagt haben wir kaufen gas kurzfristig
und werk verkaufen dass kurzfristig die
konnten dann nicht mehr mithalten die
hatten sehr schnell die steigenden
preise im portfolio und deswegen ist es
sehr wohl auf einen beginnenden
wirtschaftskrieg gegen den westen
europas von seiten russlands
zurückzuführen insofern darf das ist
schon eine krieg folge nur nicht der
kampfhandlungen dann lassen sich
trotzdem zu dem thema russland und unser
als unser energielieferant zurückkehren
jetzt im zusammenhang mit dem ukrainer
krieg
im moment wird der druck der von außen
immer größer von osteuropäischen staaten
auch von der usa
dass wir uns einem total importstopp von
öl und gas aus russland anschließend
sollen nur das wird die putin wirklich
in die knie zwingen und würde ihnen für
kompromisse oder auch möglicherweise für
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen bereit
machen was würde das eigentlich
ausmachen für die deutsche wirtschaft
für den verbraucher für die unternehmen
wir sind alle davon betroffen wirklich
alle wenn das passieren würde wenn man
von heute auf morgen von westlicher
seite den öl und gas hahn zudreht was
passiert was kostet das das weiß keiner
so richtig genau wie weit das dann durch
geht also dass die energie fehlen wird
und dass die viele unternehmen
unmittelbar betreffen wird das ist klar
nur wenn bestimmte dinge da nicht mehr
produziert werden hat das ja dann
auswirkungen auf arbeitsplätze auf
lieferketten auf nachgelagerte industrie
das ist ebenso eine weiterung die kann
potenziell die ganze wirtschaft richtig
runterreißen oder schmerzhaft bleiben
und irgendwie zu managen
das ist im moment schwer abzusehen also
beim öl wird es ein bisschen leichter
und schneller abzufangen sein weil es
alternativen gibt bei der kohle ist das
schon im vollen gange und ja auch da
sind wir auch ziemlich stark abhängig
beim gas ist es wirklich schwierig und
da ist ja dann auch ein grüner
bundeswirtschaftsminister der auf einmal
vor dingen waren die ja eigentlich gerne
schneller gehabt hätte als später
muss man das schon ernst nehmen die
regierung sagt ja auch gerade immer ist
ein bisschen
schwer für mich jetzt nachzuprüfen aber
russland könne seinen krieg mit eigenen
rubel mit gelddrucken finanzieren weil
es eine rüstungsindustrie hat und weil
die versorgung der ganzen
kriegsmaschinerie aus eigenen wirtschaft
heraus funktioniert aber der staat an
sich bräuchte die devisen- und den
erwischen wir auch schon in dem wir
zahlungssysteme unterbrechen und so
weiter und so fort das ist vielleicht so
ein bisschen eine
entschuldigung und eine art wie man sich
auch schadlos halten kann aber nur beim
gas müssen wir einfach diesen
liberalisierten markt ja auch nicht so
richtig geordnet ist und wo wir uns sehr
russland übergeben haben da müssen wir
noch ein bisschen ordnung reinbringen
und ein bisschen
sortieren ich konnte daraus gleich
nochmal zurück aber haben wir nicht eine
gewisse ambivalenz der untertitel der
sendung heißt können wir uns das noch
leisten also öl und gas aus russland
aber können wir es uns eben leisten auf
öl und gas aus russland zu verzichten
also sagen das gegenteil sind in einer
zwickmühle kommen wir da so schnell
wieder raus aus dieser frage denn wenn
die sanktion nicht effektiv genug sind
dann wird dieser schädliche krieg
möglicherweise noch länger gehen
zunächst mal ist es sehr wichtig die
regierung arbeitet mit hochdruck daran
dass diese themen gelöst werden und es
ist ein sehr wichtiges signal auch an
die menschen in diesem land die jetzt
auch natürlich die spritpreise gesehen
haben eine gewisse besorgtheit gehabt
haben zu sehen okay da wird auf allen
gebieten was getan im bereich öl ist es
so wir haben einen weltmarkt wir können
den russischen anteil substituieren es
ist möglich im bereich kohle ist es so
dass es etwas dauert die neuen prozess
wege aufzubauen wir können kohle aus
australien
sie müssen eine bestimmte qualität haben
aber das ist möglich zeitlicher vorlauf
drei bis sechs monate die regierung
arbeitet bereits daran und im bereich
gas da ist es an die größte
herausforderung denn da ist es so dass
der russische anteil schlicht zu hoch
ist ich muss mal sagen auch in einem
nachtwächter statt wo der staat nicht
zuviel eingreift darf der nachtwächter
nicht schlafen das hat die groko der
letzten acht jahre leider getan als man
immer höhere anteile russlands im gas
zulieferbereich
kapiert hat was man jetzt tun muss ist
schnell dafür sorgen dass wir mehr gas
von anderswo importieren können dafür
brauchen wir lng terminals aber auch die
brauchen drei bis fünf jahre und das
heißt wir brauchen jetzt noch fsa hughes
das sind schwimmende terminals über die
wir selber da als deutschland noch in
diesem jahr lng importieren können damit
wir genügend gas auch im nächsten winter
zur verfügung haben es ist natürlich
schon interessant dass die fdp zum
nachtwächter start spricht weil sie ja
eigentlich den start er nicht so als
wirtschafts und aber danach natürlich
daran stört ordnete die in den markt
dann mit der mutter werbung höring
vielleicht kurz haring da aber
anschließend woher wie kam es eigentlich
dass wir uns eine solche abhängigkeit
begeben haben gerade was das erdgas
angeht gegen russland aber erdöl und
kohle sind ja auch in einer hohen
prozentzahl auf dem deutschen
energiemarkt vertreten war das
leichtsinn war das kostenbewusstsein
falsches kostenbewusstsein war das
gewohnheit war das blauäugigkeit was war
das
und uns wird gerade auch sehr tragische
art und weise vorgeführt hier in
deutschland und ehrlich gesagt in ganz
europa in die brüche ich solche
verflechtungen internationalen
verflechtungen werden können
das ganze ist vor mehr als 50 jahren hat
das mal begonnen mit dem hit der
castoren geschäftig weniger wichtiges
tor ja auch arbeiten aber tatsache ist
wir haben sehr lange sehr großen wert
darin gesehen gas aus russland zu
beziehen
ich will jetzt gar nicht bewerten ob die
zahl 40 prozent depressive oder 50
prozent als jemand der seit über 30
jahren in dieser branche ist kann ich
ihnen aber sagen ein szenario das wir
jetzt diskutieren wir gehen auf null ich
glaube das haben weder wieder vegas
wirtschaftsexperten noch die politischen
experten in der frau antizipieren können
und ich kann ihnen sagen ich bin
weiterhin geschockt über das was wir
jetzt hier sehen
tatsache ist aber auch und ich glaube so
sollten wir die diskussionen erst mal
beginnen ein steht fest da bin ich
komplett bei herrn kruse die
gaswirtschaft wird sich vollständig neu
sortieren müssen was die versorgung von
erdgas nach nordwesteuropa in europa
insgesamt angeht das heißt es werden
alternativen gesucht werden müssen sie
sind bereits angesprochen worden wir
hoffen mal dass tatsächlich ähnlich
schnell geht wie herr kruse das
beschreibt und ich muss sagen ich habe
auch einen heidenrespekt vor dem
wirtschaftsminister der hier eine reihe
von kröten schlucken muss die ihm da bin
ich mir ganz sicher nicht leicht sein
die ja gerade schluckt weil er weil er
schlicht verantwortung auch hat in
seiner rolle als als wirtschafts und
energieminister
bezogen auf die kurze frist herr keller
und nun liebe mitdiskutanten glaube ich
sollten wir in der tat uns die frage
stellen was können wir uns leisten wie
der titel ja auch dieser sendung heißt
gleichzeitig müssen wir schauen was sind
die konsequenzen wenn wir ganz
aussteigen und wer auch immer diesen
ausstieg verkündet machen wir uns nichts
vor ja er kann ja auch aus aus moskau
verkündet werden das sind die
konsequenzen
sanktionen die wir verkünden werden
werden sehr vorsichtig dahingehend
entwickelt das sie idealerweise nicht
denjenigen treffen der die sanktionen
ausspricht und wir müssen die große
sorge haben ich hatte schon angedeutet
hat ja auch noch mal deutlich gemacht
wir laufen große gefahr hier dass das
industrieunternehmen und
wertschöpfungsketten die damit
zusammenhängen auseinanderfallen ich
habe mir neulich von einem einen hohen
gewerkschafter erzählen lassen wir
müssen uns vielleicht sogar fragen
und das war nur kommentiert gemeint also
nicht zu wörtlich sehen das ist
eigentlich wichtiger
industrieunternehmen bei denen man noch
einen arbeitsplatz hat oder eine warme
wohnung also wir kommen ganz ganz
schwierige diskussionen rein denn eins
steht fest
kurzfristig wäre es oder laufen wir ganz
große gefahr dass wir nicht in der lage
sind das zu managen dass es geht aber
nicht um diesen winter also den jetzt
auslaufenden aber bereits der kommende
winter kann für uns ausgesprochen
schwierig werden daher auch die
maßnahmen gebunden ist ein öl embargo
der russen was öl und gas betrifft oder
ob wir es oder die russin aussprechen
wie auch immer hätten haken hat ja
massive konsequenzen für die verbraucher
über das hinaus was wir jetzt noch
besprochen haben nicht nur die
energiepreise werden weiter steigen
möglicherweise auch die
lebensmittelpreise ist dann aus der
ukraine aus russland vielleicht auch
weniger öl weniger getreide geliefert
die logistikketten gerade im
lebensmittel und im konsumgüterbereich
können unterbrochen werden sind dann ja
auch schon angekündigt worden oder
zumindest
hat man darüber schon nachgedacht was
das bedeuten könnte für die versorgung
der bevölkerung wenn da teile dieser
infrastruktur ins wanken kommen was
bedeutet dass speziell für die
verbraucher ohne dass wir jetzt hier
alarmistisch werden
also erst mal muss man das glaube ich
trenne wir haben jetzt alle am tisch
gesagt beim öl geht es vielleicht am
einfachsten das wäre auch eine ganz eben
diese diese diesen transport einfach zu
kappen diese handelsbeziehung zu kappen
das wäre unter wirtschaftlichen
gesichtspunkten weil das meiste geld
tatsächlich die russische regierung was
er verdient eine interessante frage ob
wir das öl tatsächlich so schnell
beschaffen können und ob es dann
halbwegs vernünftig hinbekommen also ich
glaube man sollte sich wenn man darüber
nachdenkt überhaupt darauf mal
konzentrieren da geht glaube ich noch am
ehesten was teil 1 teil 2 wir werden am
ersten april wird das statistische
bundesamt die inflationsrate für den
märz verkünden und ich sage mal also bei
uns in der redaktion sagen die einen
also vielleicht ist es eine 7 andere
sagen ist es eine 8 vorne das heißt wir
werden dann einen großen an vermeintlich
einen großen schock haben dabei wissen
wie am tisch hier alle und die meisten
da draußen sich damit beschäftigen dass
das kommen wird also darüber müssen wir
nachdenken
das ist zum einen der energiepreis aber
das ist auch alles mögliche was da
hinten dran hängt was man jetzt tun wo
es damit die haushalte nie es enge haben
damit die über die runden kommen wir
müssen nämlich auch was anderes noch mal
angucken wir haben 22 und 20 21
sparquote in deutschland glaubt von 15
prozent wenn man nicht klar macht dass
das untere drittel der bevölkerung
sowieso nicht sparen kann die unseren 40
prozent haben wir anderen richtig viel
geld auf die seite legen können wir
brauchen dann in dieser situation die
hilfe nicht unmittelbar aber diejenigen
haushalte die sn haben darum wird man
sich kümmern müssen darum muss ich diese
ampelkoalition kümmern und ansonsten
müssen wir dann schauen als nächste ist
handwerker gegend also das wird es mit
dieser heizung und energiewirtschaft an
den start ziehen und so wie es
eigentlich seit jahren hätte gemacht
werden müssen damit wir im nächsten und
im übernächsten winter deutlich weniger
energie brauchen und damit auch ein
bisschen residente das ist glaube ich
das modewort im augenblick gegendruck
aus russland an der stelle sind das ist
das was man im augenblick tun muss wenn
an den armen helfen und für die anderen
denen neben mitteln zur verfügung
stellen dass die sich selber stärker
helfen können letzter punkt noch heuer
kurz juni per wollte
lng terminal in wilhelmshaven bauen im
jahr 2020 gab es dort noch mal
nachgucken da wollte bloß keiner denn
sie haben von den deutschen
gaswirtschaft wollen sie alle gesagt
haben ist zu teuer und es ist nicht
daran gescheitert dass es irgendwann ich
hätte genehmigen wollen sondern dass das
uni köln gesagt hat wir haben keine
kunden wir machen das nicht gut jetzt
haben wir die frage was sagt uns als als
alternative übrig wenn wir entweder
verzichten müssen oder verzichten wollen
auf russisches erdgas russisches erdöl
in mittelfristig lg ist der name schon
genannt worden also flüssiggas dass wir
hier aber in den helfen gar nicht
löschen können man kann auch die nordsee
nicht zum persischen golf so schnell
machen selbst wenn dort erdöl und
erdgasvorkommen drin sind und in den
angrenzenden festlands teilen von
niedersachsen und schleswig holstein was
muss jetzt schwerpunktmäßig geschehen
damit dieses mögliche defizit das wir ja
auch politisch und sicherheitspolitisch
nicht mehr wollen ausgeglichen wird
indem wir eben aus russland möglich wie
möglichst wenig noch beziehen also das
erste sind die kurzfristigen maßnahmen
wir haben ja pipeline systeme
beispielsweise mit norwegen haben
norwegen darauf angesprochen dass wir
gerne mehr kurzfristig mehr gas beziehen
möchten ganz wichtig ist darüber hinaus
dass wir für den nächsten winter
gewappnet sind der großteil des gases
wird im winter verbraucht weil eben gas
häufig zum heizen eingesetzt wird
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir schon
mit dem frühling und sommer jetzt
beginnen unsere gasspeicher zu füllen
damit wir im nächsten winter eben nicht
in die gleiche abhängigkeit geraten in
der wir in diesem winter waren deswegen
bringen wir jetzt als ampel noch in
dieser woche in den deutschen bundestag
ein gesetz ein in dem es genau darum
geht wie die gasspeicher in zukunft
reguliert werden müssen es kann ja nicht
sein dass ein russisches unternehmen 30
prozent der speicher besitzt damit
schaltet und waltet wissen möchte und
geopolitische ziele russlands verfolgt
einen krieg gegen den westen einen
wirtschaftskrieg damit auch verfolgt da
bin ich der meinung es muss
gewährleistet sein dass die kritische
infrastruktur in diesem land auch im
zugriff ist und das bedeutet wir müssen
es schaffen dass diese speicher voll
sind und dass wir hiermit nicht noch den
russischen staat die möglichkeit das
entscheiden also sie ja sagen diese gast
die gasspeicher sind in der hand oder
einige von gazprom die wiederum ja
eigentlich hier gegen unsere interessen
arbeiten möglicherweise uns auch
militärisch betonen und gleichzeitig
herrschen die hier in deutschland über
die energievorkommen das ist irgendwie
absurd das versteht keiner so darf man
nicht da darf man nicht naiv sein das
stichwort lautet mal missbrauch einer
marktbeherrschenden stellung das genau
das was russland ihren mit seinen
unternehmen in deutschland getan hat und
da darf der nachtwächter statt daneben
auch einschreiten im übrigen hat die eu
kommission in der letzten woche ein
dokument veröffentlicht in der sie sagt
solange erstens soll ein unbundling
stattfinden also eine trennung dass man
nicht liefern darf und noch speicher
besitzen hat und solange das noch nicht
gesetzeslage ist sollten die
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen union
so tun als wäre es schon gesetzeslage
das habe ich von der eu-kommission noch
nie gehört das zeigt es besteht auf
allen politischen ebenen der dringende
handlungsbedarf hier eine entflechtung
stattfindet ich würde gerne noch einen
aspekt des senders ansprechens finde ich
ja eher gering
als ergänzung in dem zusammenhang was
ich glaube wir sehen uns alle einig dass
die gasspeicher im kommenden winter
idealerweise so voll sein sollen wie es
wie es irgendwie geht kann das schon mal
eine sorge zum ausdruck gebracht für den
fall eines embargos dass das auch
einfach physisch nicht geht aber lassen
sie mich ein punkt ergänzen für den
füllstand in den speichern ist nicht
geeignet überfahren dort gespeichert
sondern das sind die händler die dort
die speicherkapazitäten buchen und eben
diese händler müssen auch die anreize
haben in diese speicher auch tatsächlich
gas einzulagern ganz einfach im moment
ist das gas im sommer teurer als das gas
im winter also kein händler der speicher
gebucht hat hat ein hohes interesse
daran dass ein zu speichern hier ist
dann eine eine regulierung wie sie
gerade diskutiert wird vermutlich läuft
sie das risiko dass händler diese
speicher gar nicht mehr buchen werden
und wir werden dann in eine staatlich
organisierte lösung reingeraten tatsache
ist wir brauchen volle speicher ich kann
nur gegen oder regierung anregen dass
sie versucht möglichst marktnah diese
lösungen zu finden die lösung die gerade
diskutiert wird läuft die gefahr dass
händler schlicht keinen speicher mehr
buchen eigentümer stellung gespielte an
der stelle keine rolle aber das würde
ich gerne noch mal einsteigen das ist
das ganze wir wollen ja wir wollen ja
genau die händler dazu verpflichten dass
sie einen teil 1 speichern und nicht die
gasspeicher besitzer insofern stimme ich
ihnen an der stelle zu nur ihr argument
dass es im winter günstiger ist gas zu
kaufen als im sommer hat uns im letzten
winter genau in diese problemlage
geführt das sollte sich nicht
wiederholen
jaja kruse ich rede doch gar nicht ich
gehe da gar nicht gegen sie ganz ganz
kurz vielleicht noch ich sehe den punkt
nur tatsache ist die speicher wenn sie
nicht gebucht sind werden dann auch
nicht gebucht und dann haben sie auch
keine verpflichtungen an ein händler der
nicht gebucht hat ist auch zu nichts
verpflichtet also die sorge die man
haben muss ist das keine buchungen
vorliegen und das muss dann gemanagt
werden das ist meine schlichte
anregungen und ich hoffe dass das mag
dich geht da gibt es konzepte da springt
allerdings den rahmen dieses dieses call
die sich gerne aber einen aspekt noch
ansprechen nämlich das thema
energiewende bisher war es ja so für
einen koalitionsvertrag raus aus dem
atomstrom dieses jahr kohlestrom 2030
gas als brückentechnologie bis zum
erreichen der klimaneutralität das ist
doch offensichtlich alles makulatur wo
es sind da änderungen zu erwarten wenn
sie es ganz kurz machen können als
kurzen aspekt noch ja also das eine ist
ja dass die grünen die ja klima wenn und
klimaneutralität stärksten vorantreiben
die haben jetzt ganz viele kröten
schlucken müssen wir haben sehr viele
dinge auch über bord werfen müssen die
versuchen jetzt natürlich dann als
alternative die energiewende
voranzutreiben das ist teil des
gesetzespaketes das auf dem weg ist das
eben schneller die erneuerbaren energien
einen großen teil der energieversorgung
übernehmen das eben trotzdem noch dann
in allen späteren wasserstoff investiert
wird und so weiter das ist der zweite
stange jetzt versucht wird die große
frage die hier keiner richtig
beantwortet ist es kostet alles
wahnsinnig viel geld weil starts gelenkt
ist und wir hatten mal eine
schuldenbremse die können wir glaube ich
dem nahm nach und überhaupt hinten
runter kippen das hätte ich jetzt auch
noch untergebracht als frage an herrn
cruz er hat mir das verhalten der
schuldengrenze jährigen 23 wieder ein
konnten das dann haben sie jetzt
gelassen hat was mit der zeit zu tun hat
und nicht dass da alle wahrscheinlich
nicht alle hier einer meinung sind eine
ganz kurze frage an sie alle noch mehr
bitte vielleicht kann man das mit einem
satz beantworten das fällt ja auf wie
groß die bereitschaft der menschen
moment ist dass wir durch umfragen nicht
nur die straßenumfragen auch durch
demoskopische umfragen sich
einzuschränken um auch solidarisch mit
der ukraine zu sein wird das einhalten
was man sie ja die freiheit hat einen
preis aber sie hat eben auch einen
großen wert und viele menschen erkennen
dass das man sie werden die leute
wenn sie merken dass ich war hat
wirklich einen preis hat ja ich glaube
das kleid dann ineinander in so ein
grundgefühl dass viele menschen auch
schon beim klimaschutz bereit sind wege
zu gehen und das geht in die gleiche
richtung das verhalten der lage ganz
kurz bitte sie noch lieber frieren als
ich eben wenn das denn funktioniert
solange wir den eindruck haben es geht
verhandlungen gut da das frühjahr kommt
ist es vielleicht ein bisschen einfacher
herr möhring ich hoffe ganz stark dass
sie recht haben herr keller die die
sorge die man haben muss an der stelle
ist das auch das im wasser des wortes
seinen preis hat dann bedanke ich mich
bei ihnen bedanken sich bei cordula
bei michael kruse bei hermann josef
tenhagen und bei ludwig möhring liebe
zuschauer morgen in der phoenix runde
flucht aus der ukraine was muss europa
jetzt
wir bleiben also beim thema beim thema
bleiben wir jetzt auch in der phoenix
runde mit meyer lieber da geht es
natürlich um die ereignisse dieses tages
in der ukraine auch die reise der drei
ministerpräsidenten darin auch ein
gespräch mit dem ukrainischen
botschafter in deutschland mit andré
melnik bleiben sie bei uns
[Musik]